So I think diversity has gotten a lot of
great, you know,
now empirical evidence that shows that
it generally works in groups, especially
in organizations and companies. But
here's the fascinating piece of it: For
companies that have a diversity and
inclusion program globally only, 8% of
them have expanded that beyond gender,
race, sexual orientation, and whatever
else, to include age. So age is not often
thought of in the diversity realm. How
it's different - STEWART BRAND: Do you want it to be? CONLEY:  I absolutely want it to be, and I think one
element of it is, you know, cognitive
diversity, which sometimes can be neuro -
how your brain works - but also,
cognitive diversity speaks to what your
experience in life is. And so I
actually think one of the beauties and
one of the few -  Europe has done a lot
more testing and studies on age
diversity than the US has, interestingly.
Partly because Europe is aging faster, and
places like Germany have actually had
to do this. What they've actually been
able to show is that age diversity has a
particularly interesting phenomena
relative to race or gender diversity, in
that gender diversity means
better collaborative skills, for sure.
But what age diversity offers is more
synthetic thinking, more of what I talked
about earlier: that ability to get the
gist of something and not to move too
quickly. So what they showed in a major
German study was a young team all by
itself makes decisions
quickly, and makes a lot of mistakes. An
older team, just older people, takes a
long time and makes fewer mistakes. When
you mix them together you get the best
of both worlds. And that's what age
diversity can offer the the
organizational world. BRAND: Brilliant, thank you.